holy crap
ladies and gentlemen it's happening you
can't stop it it's time
for fat man beyond welcome to fat man
beyond i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernardi
hey as per usual we're in two different
parts of the world but as you can see
mark
is in the sanctum sanctorum i i am
currently
in uh the cantina man scum and villainy
is my home mark sold out for
posh address in downtown new york and
stuff
um but as we normally do it from the uh
scum and villainy cantina
back in the before times ladies and
gentlemen before we had to cover our
mouths and stuff but
when we could lick handrails if we
wanted to and [ __ ]
we used to do it in the scum and
villainy cantina so in honor of that
tonight my background is coming billy
cantina but speaking of scum and
villainy cantina
i haven't said it enough scum and
villainy cantina we have news for you
about the scum and villainy cantina
being brought to you by the scum and
billy cantina
uh coutier himself jc jc jump
in and tell us your news man look at
them bamf today
i gotta figure out how to bamf in when
we get back to the bar
that'll be the real magic trick can you
pull that off
that'd be i mean never mind this show we
could take you on the road [ __ ] the show
it's all about our bamfing friend
never mind the bar you will have
conquered teleportation my friend
yeah you're no longer a bartender at
that point my friend you're a mutant
uh so la can open
restaurants for indoor dining at 25
tomorrow or yeah tomorrow we aren't able
to open tomorrow everybody's are you
opening tomorrow we can't open tomorrow
we have to reinstate insurance rehire
people
but i think what we're going to do is on
april 6th which is our four year
anniversary
do a tiny ticketed live stream event
and celebrate our fourth birthday and
then on
thursday the 8th uh open
back up so people can come in and get
their blue milk and their tater tots and
all the goodness so
fingers crossed tremendous april 8th uh
we will be back april 8th so if
what day of the week is that uh thursday
so then that means april 10th or 11th
fat man beyond will be back at the scum
and villainy canteena
we could yeah we could probably do that
i'll have to make sure the rules of
having events and all that but i think
we can probably
rule it's all a hoax
uh but yeah i think so too
we had an event at the secret stash this
weekend where we were letting in people
10 every half hour um and plenty
manageable and stuff like that so i
can't imagine
we don't get to do at least 25 percent
yeah
especially everything's spaced out and
people are in their own booths like what
we'll lose of course are the people on
the floor
but everyone will get a booth probably
and be comfy as hell
yeah i think we should have enough space
that we could probably put yeah like
30 or so people in that'd be great
that's good maybe not i mean like i've
loved doing this
version of the show not leaving usually
doing it in my robe and [ __ ] like that
bottomless nobody ever know
know that but i do miss the
vibrancy of the uh of the feedback of
the crowd like as much as
fun as the q a is uh when we stream the
show
this way from home it's so much more fun
when
you're actually looking at the people
and interacting with them during the
answer of their questions stuff like
that having people in the room
to make uh to laugh at us and stuff like
that me and mark have had to resort to
laughing at each other
and we don't want that we want strangers
to laugh at us and with us
andrew for being back at the bar will be
great andrew and i have some surprises
planned as well
for when we get back to try to bring
some of the
uh the energy and the graphics and the
animation that we've added for the
virtual shows back to the live
environment so it's just not you guys
standing behind the bar
uh chit chatting anymore we're gonna try
to uh to
liven it up and add some more uh
at the risk of sounding horrible uh add
some
fox news type elements to it so flashy
graphics and it's all
exciting not fox news content but look
we're
we're already a propaganda show people
are always accusing me of it being in
the pocket for [ __ ] marvel and [ __ ]
so
it might as well go full propaganda and
just
fox this [ __ ] up um but that's awesome
being here
streaming the show right once we're once
we're live
the show will still be streamed we'll
just have a live studio audience
with us as well very very true man um i
like the idea of uh
sprucing it up with some graphics i saw
somebody on twitter
um had a they said i you know i
look forward to the show going back to
the cantina but i like this version of
the show
because in the cantina they're so far
away on two cameras and stuff and here
it's series of close-ups so maybe
there's a move where we just
close up more on that on that front
camera and then the side camera catches
more of the bar the
the plan is to
uh get some new lenses nice and
um get some of them lenses those thin
lenses make a [ __ ] look thin
please we're gonna get yeah we'll get
some long lenses
um i think the hope is that we're going
to be streaming
at least to youtube in 4k when we get
back
so they're gonna their 4k is going to
let the audience see exactly how old me
and mark are are you sure you want to do
that
like the 4k surgery yeah we'll do the
first tune with it too though
you need to get a 4k face mark because
we're about to enter the [ __ ] world
of 4k
um
it aren't we all you just said put that
on a [ __ ] t-shirt and sell it at your
site
what is the t-shirt where do you sell it
uh the t-shirt uh there's a couple
there's the
resistances fertile t-shirt and the be
humble but let [ __ ] know
t-shirt
are both for sale at embed adult
clothing.com
okay today i'm just wearing my uh uh
sons of uldron
t-shirt i'll tell you something if i had
a sitcom
you would be the funny friend who always
wears a different t-shirt every episode
um what do you think this is man
good point this is a [ __ ] show isn't
it how are you and how was your week sir
uh i'm good i'm good the week was the
week was
interesting eventful some really good
things happening some really
interesting things happening i uh this
will probably lead into the ad we're
about to read but
i decided to reacquaint myself with the
snyder verse
in advance of zack snyder's justice
league
that's what you did with the marvel with
the marvel films you did the like deep
dive we watched everyone
in a theater before the new one came out
a few years ago yes
very on brand for you it's very on brand
for me i i did spend
what was it 30 hours in the el capitan
theater having a
16 movie marvel marathon before infinity
war
so uh i'll never recover entirely from
that but
he's got him he's got hemorrhoids named
doctor strange
thanos iron man for all that time pretty
much
my favorite is dormammu he's
particularly troublesome mark loves to
talk to his own ass he goes to it every
day he's dormammu i have a bargain for
you and he's like just wipe me
[ __ ] that's all
just stop flaring up if you if you
please uh but i watch a man of steel
um over the weekend not even like friday
i think
and it uh it emerged a better movie than
i remember it being
is that right yeah like i remember being
somewhat down on it when i first saw the
theater
and i haven't revisited it since and so
now whatever this is
six years later um i
i liked it quite a bit more than i did
the first time i still have some issues
with it i still have some problems with
it i
did a big long twitter thread um kind of
dissecting it but
his father still didn't have to die not
that way
not that way yeah that that is the crux
of the problem is
does that boy raised by that man grow up
to become superman
um and uh the guy who's like do me a
favor
never get involved no let the kids die
if they die it's fine you know don't
save me don't save anybody like why that
kid then decides to start saving people
without a compelling
counter argument which you know ma can't
doesn't really provide
and so it's how does he become this
person
um that that's that's sort of my biggest
crux of the issue and then yeah superman
shouldn't kill people
but that's but the rest of it plays
pretty damn well i've revisited
a few times since it came out and i
always thought it was an insanely well
done movie it's not
my superman the chris reeve superman the
kurt swann spit curl wink at the camera
superman and stuff
but um i you know henry cavill
absolutely wonderful and
and um in terms of the reinvention like
that score
uh zach's direction yeah it was it was a
journey
um so much so that remember then they
were like hey he's doing another one at
the start [ __ ] batman's in
the world what nuts for that so yeah i'm
uh when
where are you in the re-watch um
tomorrow i'm gonna do batman v superman
um the ultimate edition which i've never
seen before um
but that's on the hbo max so i'm gonna
i'm gonna tune into that and see how
that
has sort of aged over time because
similarly i remember not really liking
that movie when it first came out
um and so i'm curious like i'm just
curious like this this is going to be a
10 days of revisiting this stuff because
i'm curious
uh culminating with no doubt thursday's
epic re-watch
of or epic first watch of zack snyder's
justice league
that's right kids the good folks at hbo
max
are our sponsors this week for zack
snyder's justice league
can you believe it we talk about the
show for free all the time
but still they jumped on board and they
bought some mad time thank you very much
um here we are telling you about
something we were going to tell you
about regardless
zack snyder's justice league drops on
what day mark
it drops thursday the 18th thursday the
18th now
on wednesday the 17th the night before
um at 11 00 well 8 o'clock uh
uh pst i think and then 11 o'clock
est or one of those um we do a red
carpet digital red carpet event
uh that i hosted and i interviewed zach
for it and stuff like that
as soon as that special ends and i think
it's on their socials and on youtube
as soon as that ends it hands off to
zack snyder's justice league which
begins at midnight
you know as of thursday or something
like that
um because of uh the special that we
shot
i i think i'm now allowed to say it i
hope i don't get [ __ ] fired at this
point but
um i believe i was told i could finally
say something
i may have hinted at it last week mark
but you tried your best not to but
i i led you down the primrose path and
you uh you held it together
i i almost spake the anti-life equation
for heaven's sakes but i was able to
hold on to it
for one whole week but now i can tell
you i seen the snyder cut i've seen zack
snyder's justice league and it is
[ __ ] wonderful
and i said that with no hint of irony or
anything like that i mean to say
you don't have to raise someone to lower
lower somebody to raise somebody so
we won't compare it to the justice
league movie that we all saw
except to say that this is insanely
masterful this
is a poetic gorgeous elegant
looking movie four hours full of comic
book splash
pages it's as if you bought a comic book
or
a full set of a book that was nothing
but double page splash pages it's just
painted so beautifully coherent as hell
all the character development that was
perhaps missing from other variations or
versions
fully on display this is the best the
highest compliment i could pay
one o'clock in the morning on friday um
i got a link for you know kevin this is
your link to watch
justly my name splashed all over it so i
couldn't steal it or take screenshots
and stuff security
and so i says to myself like well you
know i could watch it tomorrow morning
but i was like wow
it's friday night i got nothing to do
[ __ ] it i'm gonna watch an hour of this
before i go to bed
and then i stayed up till 5 00 a.m just
[ __ ] watching it like
it moves so [ __ ] fast it does not
feel like a four-hour movie
but everyone gets introduced everyone
has their own
issue almost like of a comic book where
it's like first we spend time with diana
then we spend time with cyborg then we
spend time with so forth and so on
um flash it was
complete night and day from what we were
once told was
justice league it's a triumph like truly
i'm so happy for zach
by virtue of the fact that like you know
things went horrible in his life and
that's
part of the reason that he walked away
from justice league and
very rarely do the creative types
particularly at that very
um pricey level that zach works on are
they ever afforded a second bite at the
apple man and so it was so nice to see
that
not only was this guy afforded a second
by the apple to actually finish the
movie he wanted to make
he made the exact movie that he wanted
to make it's four hours long
it's got everything in it i talked to
him he said look there's definitely like
20 minutes we left out i was like just
20. so four hours and i'm telling you
never once was i looking at my watch i
went to the bathroom once but i brought
my laptop with me and took a leak while
i watched it and then came back
i was absolutely riveted it's they'll be
talking about this in film studies
classes for years
just in terms of like you know
it's it it steps out of the the
traditional definition of a movie which
you know to most people is like two
hours
this is four hours and you look at this
movie and you're like there's clearly
at least two movies in here man but like
it's a
giant sumptuous meal having it on hbo
max like
it makes the absolute sense i'm not
saying that because they're our sponsors
i'm saying like this is an experience
you could enjoy at home i don't know how
much of the world
would have gone out to see the four-hour
cut
theatrically but i guarantee you a lot
of people are gonna watch it at home the
big question i have is will they watch
it like i did are they gonna be
like me with like i'll watch an hour
tonight watch the rest like tomorrow and
then get
there and suddenly be like holy [ __ ] he
did it like oh my god this [ __ ] rocks
so i'm telling you you know yes they are
sponsoring us and whatnot
um and we appreciate that um it helps to
keep the lights on but let's be honest
we talk about
hbo max we talk about snyder cut all the
time we've been talking about it for a
damn year
almost like everybody else so i say this
not as a salesman
but i say this as a filmmaker i was
blown away
like i was absolutely blown away and i
was so happy for him every step of the
way because i'm like god damn it
like he he had it and then
they took it away but this is the way
that we got it again
and and we got the best version of it if
he had to cut this down
to two hours because that's not what
they did with the joss whedon he
did a lot of reshooting but if zack had
to
cut this four hour down to two um
i don't know that it it would have had
the same resonance
being able to watch this glorious
[ __ ] epic for god's sake it's like
watching the thornbirds of comic book
movies or
or you know [ __ ] shogun or something
it just goes on and on but
never boring you're always just like
yeah yeah and in many
ways it's the movie that many comic book
fans have always dreamed about where
they're like
just give me hours of this hours of it
man
there's a lot of action he's got like a
gigantic [ __ ] off action sequence
two almost every hour it feels like but
it was the character building stuff i
was most blown away with
you know [ __ ] we talk about ray
fisher and uh we've done stories about
ray and
talked about ray's issues with the movie
and whatnot
um now i get it because
he was completely cut out of that other
movie he's the star of justice league
he's the heart and [ __ ] soul of it
man
and carries it you know borg life indeed
hashtag borg life but
his performance is really wonderfully
understated
and very very cyborg to me man and he
was the big discovery for this flick
because everyone else you know we've
seen batman and superman and wonder
woman of course in in man of steel
as you mentioned at bvs but as the new
characters stepped onto the stage for
the justice league
he got the shortest end of the stick and
now with this
zack snyder's justice league with this
four hour cut his story line is fully
stated and it's beautiful and it's what
it was meant to be
so i i can't wait for people to see it
man it's been really tough not to talk
about it
and say that i saw it it's been really
tough not to talk
with other people like mark and be like
what did you think and stuff like that
so soon everybody's gonna have that
chance
and that chance is march 18th at
midnight ladies and gentlemen on hbo max
zack snyder's justice league finally
going to be released to the world one of
the biggest stories in comics
in comic book movies in entertainment
news of the last two years man and now
it's coming to its conclusion you're
actually going to see
the snyder cat remember all those people
are like there ain't no starter cut you
ain't going to see it they're not a real
snyder cutting [ __ ]
i'll tell you something remember on the
show when um
jamie cattiers was talking about going
to like a sneak screening and [ __ ]
and she describes some things about
darkseid and
that and the the same [ __ ] that the
special effects guys i met
on rise of skywalker when i was over
there and then they had worked on
justice league both of them they were
like dude let me tell you the movie was
visionary
all the [ __ ] they talked about is
literally in the movie
it wasn't a lie it wasn't like made up
it wasn't like oh well they didn't
shooters
[ __ ] shot it's all there man so i
can't wait for cats to see it is
i felt so happy for that guy i felt
happy for me too because like i got to
sit there and talk to him and
geek out about it on on the special that
happens on wednesday night
so um he's just in a good place like in
general what a year for him aside from
this which can be [ __ ] huge
two months after this he's got that
[ __ ] army of the dead movie or
whatever it's
called on netflix so good for snyder man
it's the year of zach and it honestly
couldn't happen to a
nicer guy he's a real sweet dude um but
that ain't a reason to watch a movie
just because somebody's nice if it was
i'd be the most [ __ ] successful
filmmaker in hollywood and as we all
know that's not true
so niceness aside it's a [ __ ] great
film
it's true and it's a film this is
something they'll study in usc and ucla
and nyu
film studies classes and stuff like that
it's classy as [ __ ]
can't wait for you to see it man when
does it happen mark give them their call
to action
their call to action thursday march 18th
hbo max
zack snyder's justice league finally
released to the world
and something tells me that you and i
will get to talk deep and long about it
um after i get to see it on thursday and
for the next podcast
whenever that may be probably saturday
maybe sunday
um we'll we'll dig into it for reals
absolutely in the next episode of fat
man beyond kids
we're going to dive deep into the crack
of zack snyder's justice league man
probably be like the whole episode and
[ __ ] like that as it comes out
just on thursday and we'll reconvene on
saturday or sunday as mark said
and gush or talk about it we'll see i'll
gush and probably mark
mark will pick
um all right enough about [ __ ] dc man
uh let's talk about marvel kids because
we got special guest
he was name check last week while we
were
talking to matt shakman and that's how
this all happened because he went on
twitter
we gave some love we have a justice
league trailer
that we could show from hbo do we want
to try it and see if
youtube kicks us off that's true we're
always leery about
going video material kids in case like
youtube
somehow reads it as us violating
something but
they did give us footage to show so
let's let's show it and hope to god
if we get thrown off youtube apologies
ladies and gentlemen it's happened
before but
run the clip it's nothing you've never
seen before they didn't give us any
original stuff but it's a pretty damn
look at that
dark side granny goodness assad i
watched all of this man i've seen all
this in context i miss a trailer it's
very exciting
but i've seen all this in action man and
there was a lot
there's a lot of reshooting that had
been done man like that whole sequence
where barry saves iris for the first
time and then we just
found out this week that the girl plays
iris is coming back to play iris in the
flash food
very very cool sweet all right so maybe
since we didn't hear it
maybe youtube won't throw us off are we
still on youtube
amen um apologies in advance kids if i
slur any words
it's not because i'm drunk i don't like
to drink i hate drinking i love weed and
you know i'm always stoned
um but i had that uh periodontal surgery
and stuff
so some molars came out on each side so
my my tongue is such a weird thing i
never encountered before
my tongue the back end of my tongue
spills out now
into my mouth and so periodically you're
like she felt he fell
by this it's very strange so i was glad
i was never one of those kids that made
fun of people that
slurred their words because now that's
all i'm [ __ ] doing and as a person
who speaks for a living
did you just hear it i said speaks is
like speaks it's kryptonite i sound like
daffy [ __ ] duck i'm gonna lose all my
cool
jobs i was so scared they weren't gonna
let me do the zack snyder special
because they're gonna hear me talk and
be like
bro you can't even say superman without
spitting on us and [ __ ] like that
so i apologize if you hear any slurring
words or something it's my dental work
that's going on
all righty duck is on brad for warner
brothers though you're not kidding
hbo max is very happy for us too for me
to sound like both the sylvester and
daffy duck
uh back to what we were saying last week
we had matt shakman on the show talking
about wanda vision
matt shakman name checked he's very kind
most people
talk about themselves like me he started
giving out credit to all the other
people that helped make wanda vision
come to life
and one of those names uh was andy park
and andy
tweeted about it and so i i liked it
mark saw it and we were like let's grab
him man let's see if he'll
come on to talking by god he's come on
to talk to us man from marvel studios
ladies and gentlemen the guy without
whom
you don't get to see the heroes that you
see on the big and little screen give it
up for our guest tonight mr andy park
hey what's up guys captain how are you
i'm doing great thank you so much mark
and kevin for having me on um i'm a big
fan of of both of you guys
so this is the god damn world that's why
we brought you on whoever you liked it
we're like get him he likes it
andy explain to all the cats at home uh
you know there are definitely people in
our audience well studied know exactly
who the [ __ ] you are
but to the cats at home who are casual
marvel fans
explain to them what your exact position
is in marvel studios
okay um i'm my title is director of
visual development
and i'm part of a group of artists in
the visual development department of
marvel studios it was
formed back in 2010 um
by charlie nguyen and ryan meinerding
they were pivotal
in the early marvel film from iron man
to captain america
and thor and around that time right
before they're about to start avengers
kevin feige you know and the leadership
of marvel said
i think it would behoove them to create
an in-house group of artists
knowing that they're going to have
connected films for years to come
because normally if people don't know
normally
concept artists that work on these films
that design these characters and
scenes and stuff like that are
freelancers so they only come on for a
little bit
then they get laid off and they have to
go find another film so this kind of
department is unique
so for the first few movies that was how
they function they hired somebody like
you know the same way in the movie biz
you hire somebody to do a function
but they were all freelancers once the
job was over they moved on
and if they like their work maybe they
bring them back but that marvel did not
at that point
have its own built-in division of
artists that they kept on staff all the
time
exactly it was like the very first like
iron man working on that john favreau
and bringing on um in particular ryan
meiner ding phil sanders and adi granov
which i think you know
um that name and they were so
instrumental normally the you know
concept artists just do the design
then they kind of leave but this was a
situation where they stayed on and was
actually working with
at that time stan winston um studio to
build iron man armor so they were
working with the designers the concept
artists that did the initial design
and work together as they're making it
into an into
something that's real and as marvel saw
that kevin saw that they saw wow this is
something very um advantageous something
to have and kevin's really
into like art um and illustration so i
think
he built that relationship with with um
ryan in particular
and then that's when you know they
brought him back to you know work on
captain america he was pivotal for that
look and feel and then charlie was
pivotal for thor
and then when when they're about to
start avengers that's when i got the
call
saying hey we're forming this in-house
group of artists just like they're
forming the avengers on screen
and that was that was like a dream call
where i was like yes of course and then
i've been there since
since then so this is my 11th year there
and our
whole job is to design the characters
the villains
and to come up with the visual tone look
in key frames um for the films so in
many ways
we've seen in the behind the scenes
stuff on some of the
video releases and whatnot or on youtube
um
before even a writer or a director
comes into the project you guys are
actually at work is that correct
yes totally um a lot of times like for
for example guardians of the galaxy
there was no james gunn wasn't hired yet
there was no script
kevin just came to our you know our
office and said hey we're going to be
working on
guardians of the galaxy you know that
blew my mind as a marvel comic fan
growing up i was aware of that
but i was like after the success of
avengers you would never expect they
would be doing
gardening like every marvel comics fan
you were like that
exactly pick that exactly i was like i
can be out of a job soon but
you know that's that speaks to the
genius of kevin feige right he didn't
truly
he's not just going to do what the
typical executive is going to do
he has a bigger vision and then for
there from that
that point we spent two weeks just
coming with designs
you know it was like blue sky whatever
we wanted
so think about this kids that means that
you know for years groot has been in the
comics
but somebody actually had to before
there was a james gunn involved
one of the artists had to be like what
would groot look like
for real and had to now how close
is that original passive group to what
we saw on the big screen
um that's what's great because because
we're full time we we work
even after the concept art we spend
months doing the concept art
you know showing to the executives and
um all the leadership and then that gets
approved
we often work with you know we also have
a 3d in-house modeler at that time was
josh herman
currently adam ross and then we work
even with the vfx houses or the costume
designer if it's a
real practical character and we work
with them to kind of
basically get that initial vision to
to be to you know hold its way through
to the final
what you see on film and even a lot of
times we even work in post
so like for example when i was working
on hella i even worked
um in posts with the vfx studios trying
to get her
looked really solidified and that her
look was even evolving
in that that step of the process so
that's that's another unique thing about
our department when you guys were
designing
uh hella in particular was there ever a
moment where somebody's like we can't do
the [ __ ] horns we can't do those
antlers
yeah that was me from the very beginning
when taika came to us and said it wasn't
cast yet and he's like we're doing
hella and i was like oh that's so
awesome because the more comic book it
is
you know i'm a huge like comic book fan
especially marvel
that that's you know that's more fun
than the more like tactical real world
stuff
which is fun too but that one was one
like my job as a concert artist knowing
that it's going to be live action
is to try to make it real how do we make
it believable
right so i did you know i um i did
versions where it's smaller because
you know knowing that every time she
turns her head it can't be this big old
like
wide angle thing so the other option
that i had was like
hey we can still get the silhouette but
let's put on her back you know you still
get the silhouette
now the actress can move tycho was like
no he wasn't having that he's like i
want jack kirby
so i was like okay so i went against
everything that you know
that i'm trained to do as a concept
artist but i did it i did these
big old big old ass like antlers
and he was like wide or whiter like it
was essentially
six feet wide and that was one and i
spent like
months it probably took about six months
to finally get like fully approved
and it was one of those designs where i
did it and i was like i don't know how
they're gonna do that in vfx but
i did what i was told so did you know
that they would do [ __ ] like where she
white
pretends to wipe her hair back and then
they pop out was that part of the
imagining early on yeah that's why it
took six months because it wasn't just
doing that one version
i was doing what you know versions where
the antlers were smaller there was you
know early on there was versions that
even the antlers would cover and create
a mask um
you know without the mask you know just
a little a little bit here
a little bit you know covering more so
there's all these different versions
that she would have
so um i didn't remem i don't think they
told us that she was necessarily going
to be doing that
whatever i don't know if that happened
during filming or what but when i saw
that i was like
and then of course when they told me kid
bla bla and [ __ ] i was like oh my gosh
so that's right so you start drawing
these people without knowing who the
people are yeah exactly and a lot of
times i'll like you know
i'll try to cast them myself
as long as you've come never never been
successful in casting
you're no kevin feige man that's yeah
i'm sure
what is it like working for feige man we
imagine that we hear a worship maybe
one of my if not currently my favorite
filmmaker working today
because he is telling one gigantic story
he's using a bunch of directors to do it
but he's show running like my favorite
piece of entertainment that's currently
being made
was it like working for the guy you said
before he likes the visuals
yeah yeah it is uh it is i always talk
about him i always gush about him
because
you know i worked this 26 years as a as
a professional artist
and this guy you know it's so nice to be
able to work for someone
that's elite that's the head of the
studio that you believe in
that you genuinely believe in and you
know i go to the meetings you know as
i'm leading
the the films certain films i go in you
know in a room of 25 people
all the different heads of every
department kevin's there
and so often like he'll say something
and i'm you know i don't say it out loud
but in my head i'm just like oh my gosh
he gets it
oh my gosh he gets it like his choices
are just like amazing like he really
gets
he has that perfect combination of he
knows the source material he's a fan
of the comics you know he's not afraid
of it like you know
and and then he's a great filmmaker like
you know you might have one but
it's very hard to find someone who has
both of these things especially with his
resume and working with
you know honor back in the day and just
so and he and all the comic book films
he has so
so he is amazing and he's someone that
like
you know every every time i show him a
piece of artwork
you know the the critiques that he'll
have the little choices
it's usually very concise so why don't
you try this or that
you're just like yes yes why didn't i
think of that
it seems as if like for for a long time
in hollywood
the the look of the movie seemed to be a
little afraid of being what the comic
books were
you know like the the best example i
think is like the x-men
at first where it's we're not going to
put them in yellow and blue because
we're never going to do that so it
becomes black leather becomes matrix a
bit
what's the philosophy that you hold when
you're looking at these books and these
characters from the books
in bringing them to the screen because
it feels like there's some fidelity
you're definitely trying to convey yeah
and i think that's the
um great thing about working in this
department because there's a it's not
just myself there's a whole group of
artists that work there
full-time and freelance and i think
something that
i bring to the table because of my
background i used to draw comic books
right to
my first job was working for rob
lightfield um so
i could what years what years were you
working for livefield
95 through 97. oh the hot years man that
was like during the image years when
everything was blowing up and on fire
and that's when chasing amy came out and
we're like you know hanging out with my
anchor friends i was like oh my gosh i'm
so perfect
because i didn't know what anchors were
or two until i got hired i'm like
what you just cop will go over my
pencils
for a guy that read comics i remember
the first time the notion of the anchor
was introduced to me and walter was like
i was like who drew this and he was like
this person but this person inked it i
was like what do you mean ink he's like
well somebody draws it in pencil
and then somebody comes in and draws on
top of it and pen
and that's the lined artwork and i'm
like well isn't that just tracing and
he's like well
yeah i guess it is so like the chasing
amy scene was
you know kind of uh like a a a
quasi-insider's comic book world
joke that has haunted me ever since then
because every anchor i mean i went on to
work with jimmy palmiotti on daredevil
i was like tracer am i you
that was perfect because the waiter so
you were you were working in comics
for you so is that how kevin knew your
work he's like i see i like his stuff
let's get him
no it was really through i mentioned
ryan manning and charlie nguyen in the
beginning because i worked with him
um after comic books i went into concept
art working for god of war the sony
playstation video game
so i worked on gut war two and three and
then they left
those two and started getting to film
and then once i got into marvel
you know because of that connection they
gave me a call once they decided they
wanted a formed team
but um mark just to answer sorry i'll go
on go ahead no go go hit him sorry oh
i wanted to answer your question mark um
um so
yeah i think something that i i feel
like i bring to the table is
you know i'm i am still like a fanboy
like i you know i
love these characters and especially
marvel
and i feel like the concept designs that
i do
will always try to be like i always do
the one that's like okay this is like
you know i give them a range like the
more comic accurate one
and then you start doing like okay let's
let's see how far
we have to go and it really depends on
the director every director has
their own inclinations and some are like
by taiko's like i want jack kirby
that's kind of rare right others you
could tell they're a little bit more
afraid to go
like it's a little campy um so that like
even josh like right he's
working on age of ultron that's when i
did the first design
for um wanda um the very first painting
i did i gave her like the you know the
crown and everything
knowing that okay they're not gonna go
for this because this is
why is she wearing that that's the good
thing about marvel studios films like
there's usually a reason right
uh whether some kind some level of
believability
you know that's something they've
established so really
to answer your question it really kind
of depends on the director
and sometimes they lean towards like
okay
we want it to look like the comic but
you know other ones that you've seen are
like oh they're
we've taken some liberties but overall i
feel like the track record is
decent as far as like satisfying the
comic book fan
absolutely agreed here's my question
about juan you talked about drawing her
for age of ultron
so that was the first design of wanda
did you work on the wanda vision design
of the scarlet witch's outfit did you
ever draw that
yeah i designed the the final one so
that was like um
that was the dream because i designed i
did her concept design for
for captain america civil war and that
one
for the russo brothers knowing that
their taste is a little bit more
grounded
i still wanted something here so i i did
this one design where
i gave her like this headband just to
like you know suggest it right
knowing again they're not gonna pick
that and yeah they didn't pick that one
so when when um mary lovanos came to me
the producer
of one division and pitched the show to
me it was one of those like
yes
[Laughter]
finally so yeah i got to do her design
and um
wait so did you put the hidden mine
stone the vision homage in her collar
caught that huh yeah the internet the
internet caught that long before me
and not a dry eye on twitter the day
that went out
like so many i'm crying with the like
the picture of the
of the if you look closely kids if
you're not following along
uh the scarlet witch's costume in her
collar
has a little piece of vision it's the
outline
of the mind stone so that he's always
with her which is so
[ __ ] beautiful where did that little
detail come in
that's that's the fun of my job right
because where i'm spending
days and hours and hours and days coming
with different versions like
to just come up with that wanda or that
scarlet witch design that you saw on
screen like i did
dozens and dozens and meetings upon
meetings and so i'm
thoroughly doing research trying to come
up with ideas something else that you
see
in her kind of this chest area is it's a
subtle
i don't i don't i'm not able to show it
i'm actually going to be posting on my
instagram tomorrow by the way
that's when i'm allowed to show it but
if you notice around here there's
a subtle like w yes below that is a v
wanda vision right so there's things
like that that you throw in there that
you know audiences might not they don't
necessarily catch those kind of things
but as a designer
just like car designers whatever you
know they throw in things and themes and
different languages that you know the
normal person might not catch but
it's it's what makes these designs more
deeper and gives it some level of
it makes it fun for us you know you see
this stuff long before we do so when did
you first design
uh the wanda costume for one division
like what year was that
oh man i remember i was at san diego
comic-con
because i had a booth so now
i had to have a meeting for her to
finalize her costume so i ran
to my off to my hotel room and went on
zoom or it wasn't zoom was i forgot what
it was
blue jeans or something that with kevin
feige but i think that was like
gosh what was that 2018
17 18 i think you draw a thing
and then you don't get to see that thing
realized sometimes for two three years
yeah i mean the the good thing is the
other part of my job is right
after i design it i work we work very
often with the costume designer
so oh so it keeps going yeah so in this
case i'm working with uh
maya's rubio and then the um the
specialty costumers and jose
fernandez and iron head and they're the
ones who came you know and then our 3d
modeler and adam ross
were um then we'll actually start
they'll start like building it they'll
show it to me i'll go to the fittings
you know with lizzy and i'll see it
you know in progress and then you kind
of it's such a treat such a treat you
know finally seeing it with lizzy
at the end you're just like oh my gosh
are the actors allowed input like can
lizzie be like can we do this can we do
that can we yeah
yeah yeah definitely they i mean not not
usually like
early on during the design phase but
when when they're actually building it
there's a lot of times where it's like
okay i cannot lift up my arms you know i
remember
you know that happened with certain
actors and those costumes are very
uncomfortable
you know so it's always like the first
time you know an actor wears it they're
like oh they're excited because they're
like i'm a superhero
and then in the sequel you could tell
[Laughter]
change this
in terms of the artwork oftentimes
they'll show us when a movie comes out
or a show comes out
the concept artwork and like sometimes
they are literally frames
from the movie how often is that the
case so really the question should be i
guess
how often is a con a piece of concept
art
not wind up being captured by the
filmmaker
oh man i mean you're seeing it right now
like that's a keyframe i did for jaws
for
avengers he described it as the
dilophosaurus moment
you know where the dinosaurs you know
and so this is all iron man's pieces
come out so as you can see
it's not one to one but it's the
inspiration it's the
you know essence of that moment and
that's kind of the purpose of
not only we do costume designs and
character designs
but we also do what are called key
frames just an individual story moment
so a lot of times
you know there you could tell it's what
inspires the
final but there are a lot of times where
it's like oh my gosh
like when i'd be at the premiere with my
co-workers and we'd see a shot and like
oh my god that looks like exactly
like your keyframe so it's it's kind of
cool kind of cool to see that
um to go all the way back when was the
first time
you knew that being a concept
illustrator was a job you could do
happened you know like the early days of
the internet right so when i was
first drawing for rob liefeld eventually
i worked for mark silvestri top cow
drawing tomb raider um the internet was
still
quite new and then um once i started
seeing
artists and their website because i went
to art school and that's where i learned
how to paint
and do full illustrations do realism and
comic books i'm doing more stylizing
only with a pencil
so once i started seeing like that i was
like oh that's a job
like concept art for video games and
movies that really spoke to me
because um you know and as video games
especially video games became more
you know graphic heavy that's when like
concept bars became more important you
know versus the early days right where
it's just 8-bit
so it was the internet that really
started like revealing like oh my gosh
like i can do full
illustrations designing characters you
know because i love characters
that's the story of the part of the
story that i love um contributing
to so yeah it was really when was that
like
kind of the early 2000s
or kind of mid like 2000
yeah kind of early 2000s how hard is it
to keep the secrets andy that's what
that's what i'd be fired for
because i'd constantly be like you got
to see this outfit like you're [ __ ]
fired
how hard is it to keep quiet for like
two three years at a clip because you
know
the magic that's coming for example on
uh
end game you know [ __ ] cap holding a
holding mullin here somebody must have
drawn that as a keyframe i'm sure
yeah that's right to sit on that
information
for as long as he had to and only
telling the people who were involved in
the production
that seems like the most difficult part
of the job
it's it's so hard because um
man even like i don't even tell my kids
or my wife
right because they're fans of these
films so i want them to enjoy it
um so it's and so my friends they they
ask me all the time but
um i'm legally not bound to but
even beyond that i want people to enjoy
this and it's it's really hard because
i'm like
oh my gosh wait till you see you know
wait till you see oh my gosh it's gonna
be
crazy what happens and there's so many
things that i right now i'm like i'll
wait till you see like
these future movies oh my gosh i would
imagine like end game though which was
such like a
[ __ ] epic and eventually a movie that
involves literally every piece of marvel
ip that's ever been in the marvel
cinematic universe
that would be something that i'd
constantly want to like if somebody was
like uh
tell me what happens i was like i can't
can you guess okay i'll let you guess
like 20 heroes showed up no 50 heroes
show up
no all the [ __ ] hero i would lose my
job so [ __ ] fast
you're a good man and it's a good reason
that you're keeping it quiet too because
it is
as much as we love spoilers and we want
to know what's coming we want all the
information
we can possibly get and glean and
towards the marvel flicks because we
love them
the element of surprise makes it so
[ __ ] incredibly amazing it's so
magical to watch that movie
i will never forget the thunderous
thunderous reaction
to the mole in your soaring through the
air and people for one second being like
but how and then finding it in the hand
of cat and
everybody going nuts man just screaming
like so [ __ ] crazy i'm glad i didn't
know that was gonna happen
because i screamed right along with them
and stuff but as a fan of this [ __ ]
i also want to know what's happening so
when you were like there's even stuff
now i'm like ooh what stuff
are you talking about yeah i've been
watching a lot of those audience
reaction videos in the last year
i need to feel something good show me
the good things
computer i would like
exactly there's always it's always
avengers reactions
and we were there together we were there
together at the avengers premiere right
which one you went oh i think i know
kevin you were there
i was there i was yeah i i had fallen
off marvel's list
by that oh no i was just a dude
all right so if if you were working on
one division
uh like two years ago or actually three
years ago at that point in terms of like
hey we're going to head in this
direction we're going to need
concepts we're going to need costumes
with i i
don't want you the spoiler get in
trouble but we know the movies that are
forthcoming so yeah we know that black
widow's forthcoming did you work on that
yeah i led the team on that one that was
you led the [ __ ] team on it
on the biz dev team so i got to because
i got to design
um black widow throughout the years um
and then i
designed um taskmaster as well so i'm i
cannot wait for that film it's so
you did [ __ ] you did task master yeah
that was fun
he looks fantastic man we've only seen
him in the trailers but he looks badass
i saw his pop though recently
which looks amazing um all right so
there's
black widow um eternals is after that
did you get to work on that
shang cheese before that right is
shangchi before the eternals no yes
yes is it really was it is it july or
june i forgot so it goes black widow
shang chi and then the eternals
i think spider-man is wait when is
spider-man coming out i don't even
remember
i don't even know anymore because you're
working on 19 things at once
yeah you're working on the future as
well not spiderman what am i talking
about that's isn't that next year i
don't even know
i think it's that yeah they're almost
done shooting so next year yeah so
yeah all right but it's like widow
internals in the next year is spider-man
and doctor strange oh you're right
you're right all right well here's a
question we know down the road
blade is happening is somebody concept
arting blade right now
oh yeah you know we're working on like
all these films right now
right or not all of them but you know
their stuff
and pretty much any time we hear a title
of a film i would imagine
you guys have already started before we
even hear what's coming
well i mean i know they started
to a degree i just you know when it
comes to the what we work on
like the only ones that i can say that
we started working on like i'm working
right now on
um on captain marvel 2 and ant-man
you know and the wasp quantomania
what happens no so wait are you just i
mean
i don't know if you can talk about but
because i don't think they've officially
come out and said it but
rumors on the internet is kang is a big
figure
um in in quantum mania so if kang was a
big figure in quantum mania
somebody would be designing him right
now
he has already designed step
carefully i know i know
we'll leave you off the hook on that one
um it's just so thrilling to think about
the idea that like
a movie that we've heard a name for that
there are a bunch is a team of artists
already working on
uh images and more importantly the key
frames
that light our hearts on fire like
seeing that moment you guys are
manufacturing that moment long before we
ever get to
see that moment play out man you're
breathing rarefied air
not only not only are you seeing things
that we don't get to see you're
literally creating the things that we
don't get to see
god that must be amazing a lot of times
we'll you know create designs of
characters or keyframe moments that
don't end up
making the movie right because we're you
know there's so many different versions
or changes
and then now they're like okay that's
not in the film anymore so those things
happen all the time too
is that hard for him are you like that's
what i was gonna ask like how often do
you design something that you think is
like awesome
you should do this for that and then
they're like we're gonna go a different
way you like but you guys this
yeah it's definitely heartbreaking as an
artist right as a concept designer but
um you know we're there to serve the
story we're not there to showcase our
designs and artwork so you know we have
to have that perspective
and you know ju it's it's you must be so
disciplined
to not like it would be so easy to be
the king of instagram
by dropping this stuff early people be
like he's got all the [ __ ] good stuff
but you show wonderful restraint in as
much as you're mentioning that
only tomorrow you're allowed to put up
something in regards to
wanda yeah yeah i'm gonna be posting the
um the scarlet witch design that i did
and so they give you a date where
they're like you can share
before this you can't do [ __ ] uh
it's in in the past it's usually been
once you know the
the films or projects are released but
usually we have like um art books
that come out with in conjunction with
this but this is a situation where
um the art book for one division hasn't
come out yet
so this was this required like special
permission
what has been the best part of the job
so far in terms of
sure drawing of course when you're
wonderful at drawing and being able to
express yourself
but in terms of like holy [ __ ] like
what's been the fun kind of i can't
believe i work in a movie business
moment for you
uh definitely when i first got hired
like you know avengers cuz you know
growing up
in the 80s with talking with my friends
like it was always like you can never
have an avengers film you can't have
that many like main characters you know
you can't have six of them
then in game happens so work i remember
working on that film
um being that first moment like i cannot
believe i'm
you know working for marvel studios on
avengers
there's just been so many moments i
think working on ant-man and the wasp
was special because
that was one where i was flying back and
forth from la i live in la
to atlanta to um where the production
was working with the cosplay designer
and trying to and work and going to the
fittings with paul and evangeline
trying to get these suits to um become
fully realized
and then going on set um you know
seeing peyton and watching them film and
seeing you know it started with a blank
page
obviously you know we start with the
source material of jack kirby and
stanley and steve ditko all that stuff
but i'm talking about the blank page for
concept design for the film
and all the all the time blood sweat and
tears you know
trying to get these approvals and then
to watch them
film you know that i think that one was
very special too and then of course
going to the premieres
and then so so many of these are like
it's so hard to pick like
oh it's one thing because i feel like
every single film is like i have those
moments of just like
i have to pinch myself so i'm like oh my
gosh this is crazy what
and especially what they're building
because like ant-man was a film where
you're like
okay my this is going to be the end of
the mcu right because you're like
after avengers you're going to do a
character named ant-man it's kind of
ridiculous right
right so and then that was you know
successful okay it's definitely
regarding the galaxy that's going to be
the end of the mcu
that does well the current the current
version of that is the eternals like
come on come on
this seems like a bridge too far but
it's gonna work again just like they are
yeah
yeah it's funny how people still say
that even after all these years
but they haven't they've proven
themselves you know so it's like
it's it's kind of amazing what kevin
feige and all of them can do
was there a difference in the workload
between one division
and say one of the features i mean given
the length of i mean one division is as
long as three is two movies three movies
so how does that change the amount of
renderings that you and your team are
doing
it was it's it was actually almost
same as a little different because
there's like less like super
hero type of or villain type of
characters to design
so that one is very besides you know you
know the
agatha and and wanda and vision um those
characters
it was very keyframe heavy so um the
group of artists i was working with
was was doing like a ton of those kind
of moments from um
when monica's you know her becoming or
just gaining her powers as she's going
through the hex jana shermer was
doing that design or the initial designs
of what does the hex look like
when like the military vehicles come
through and jackson z
um our resident amazing artist was doing
that those key frames and when wanda is
like first forming the hex
so because they wanted to see like what
does this look like because it's very
weird and having the tv static and stuff
so what are these visuals what can they
look like
so it kind of starts with us and then we
go back and forth and then
eventually they you know hand it over to
the vfx to
fully fully flesh it out did you do
agatha as well
no that one initially was done by one of
ours janna shermer and then eventually
um maya's rubio and her artist did the
final her
look for her um was there ever like in
the comics of course she's got white
hair she's a little old lady
was there ever like well we gotta put
white hair on her and it just went away
i i don't think there was no i don't
remember ever seeing a white hair
version for her
um i thought it was a good choice like
the whole time when people were like i
think it could be again the harkness and
stuff
and when she finally revealed herself
and she had her own hair or at least
like dark hair
i was glad she wasn't like the
white-haired old lady version yeah
yeah what has been go ahead marco i was
just gonna say it must be hard
to to like have to pick a favorite child
but
is there one of your designs that is the
closest to your heart that you feel like
this is the most me it changed the least
from from idea to execution
it's the one i'm most proud of you know
not that you need to throw shade on
anything
else but be like you know what that's
the one that's that's the one when i get
an oscar
that's the song they play out when i get
my oscar
it is really like picking who do i like
better my daughter or son
which is impossible of course but um
i mean this this scarlet witch one was
was pretty darn awesome and just seeing
it
the reveal um i think before this one
came out i i would usually say like
ant-man you know i really really loved
designing that character especially
given like even though you know it's
cool the old jack kirby design but it's
inherently kind of like goofy and kind
of ridiculous right
so be able to take that and then bring
it into you know our world and
still be a little goofy in some ways
right it had to be clunky
look like built in the 60s but still
make it cool for modern day so that was
a unique challenge
so i would say can i say two that one
and wanda for now
it's yours yeah yeah that's fine do you
so does somebody like did you come up
the concept that like i'm gonna press
this and it's gonna go away
oh that one i think that one with uh for
this
for with peyton i think there was talk
of like is there a way that it's not
just
you know so then you know i started
doing
designs of like what can it look like
and because knowing that it's
it has it always has to be there always
has to be a contrast with stark
technology
like for for pin technology it has to be
more
analog right it can't be like tony's
eventually
and disappearing like where the hell did
it go right right versus ant-man's you
kind of want to feel it and see it so
that's why
i always had to be like okay you need to
see it even though even this is still
impossible to do but at least it's like
you know you could see it and
it makes sense in movie magic so i think
that one was
one that peyton wanted to do i just we
just had to figure
out you know how to how to um it's so
ex exciting or uh interesting to me
and both actually to hear that there's a
thought
process where that involves statements
like
well pim technology would not look as
slick as stark
technology like that attention to detail
in the world can only come from people
who are fans of the material
yeah and that's that's the fun of the
job because we're we're deep diving into
the the whys the
the whos and like with the whats when it
comes to each of these
each of these designs right so again
it's like it's stuff that the
the casual viewer
won't pick up on but that's the kind of
the stuff that
you know will subconsciously make things
like okay that's what
that's believable you know that feels
different than stark tech because if it
just looked like star tech
that would be a problem you know i think
that would be that would be something
that then people would pick up on that
right right yeah and then honestly and
oddly enough too like that detail would
pull them out of the story like that's
not real as if any of this shit's real
it's so convincing as a fan that you buy
it like you know i'll buy pseudo-science
that doesn't make sense
like until you were like it's impossible
for that helmet to actually work like
that i was like oh man
like who is it really impossible
yeah they do it all the time um it is um
is there an oscar for this position
no no unfortunately like there's no um
no
the closest would be a custom design so
costume designers you know get nominated
um like like ruth carter you know she
got the oscar for
black panther and that was a film that
ryan mannarding led the visual
development
department so um kind of like one for
production
there should be a production production
design so production design they do all
the
the environments the sets you know the
vehicles
all that kind of stuff but we work
mainly with the characters the heroes
the villains
costumes and there's no particular like
oscar for that
i think between that and stunts we
should we should make a push
um for the officers to start recognizing
these craftsmen who've been doing this
job
yeah yeah definitely beginning of
hollywood and also like in
terms of this job like you i can't think
of a more essential
stepping stone in the process like every
filmmaker
it sounds like that comes to the table
and it doesn't sound like it based on
just what andy said but
in my reading about marvel over the last
decade
every um person that steps up
uh to the table so to speak
god i'm so stoned i forgot my point what
was i trying to say
i think it was a valid point how crucial
the the concept illustration is how
crucial it is actually to have that step
somebody who envisions it because as i
was that's what i was trying to say
based on what i've seen i don't think a
single marvel director with the
exception of maybe
favreau at the beginning has ever come
to the table
with nothing except a script it sounds
like
when they hire you you're like here's a
script and here's a bunch of
what it could and should look like
yeah yeah and i think that is uh
definitely like you saw like those
making behind the scenes one division
you see you see the walls
like a lot of that stuff in the artwork
that under that was on the walls was
comic book you know source material but
a lot of it was also our
art you know because that they they
plaster along the wall
and then whenever people come by writers
and
other people in the production you know
they that that's their source of
inspiration hopefully that's the best of
you know the hope at least that they can
be like oh cool we're going to be doing
this moment
it might not be exactly this but or it
might a lot of times it is exactly that
so yeah and i think that's something
that kevin feige definitely
embraces and recognizes so you know all
thanks to him that he
embraced our whole department
it makes the movies better it's just
that simple you know it's
basically think about it in terms of
when movies come together let's say you
got a director being hired to direct
somebody's script
if they were to just start the process
there
you don't get the long lead that these
cats do
in their department where they're like
thinking about it and drawing it out
two three years in advance of of
somebody actually stepping onto a set
so when you get to the making of the
movie you don't spend
uh two six months in pre-production
trying to figure out what it'll look
like or what the characters look like
a lot of the work has been done like
we've already kind of envisioned this
so take this and run with it man like
it's
in terms of big budget studio filmmaking
it it very much is a collaborative
process it sounds like
yeah but i think i just think a lot of
other studios aren't just set up this
way right
because this disney's or marvel studios
is in a unique situation
where you know they have their
leadership set versus a lot of other
films that are made out there
it's they have to build a team build you
know find the director find this
and then they have to hire the artist
and stuff like that versus
you know kevin feige he's always there
he's leading it and
we're always there so okay you could
always just walk over to us
or call us on zoom now and say hey
years later we want to do this can you
guys start doing artwork
and it also sounds kind of cool it seems
like innovation happens
when you have the desire and the
wherewithal to build departments like
this you know you don't get ilm
unless george lucas is like you know
what i don't want to go to outside
vendors i don't want to do i want to
build a team myself
that can always be working up always
refining and always figuring out ways to
stream on the system
and i think to your point like yeah
we're we're honestly saving marvel money
and we're making the projects better by
all of us being on staff and all of us
being here
yeah i think um lucasfilm is they also
have that right they're the only ones
that
essentially has that kind of department
as well so i think it's only
them and um marvel i'm not sure i know i
know there's been other students that
have attempted to create this
but i think it's the other studios are
so big they're such
behemoths that it's really difficult to
try to centralize and
make this like just departments you know
there's too many leaders it's beautiful
because it is marvel
of course one of the big tentpoles in
comic book history
paying homage to their comic book roots
by
like bringing artists in to be like hey
realize these characters
for us before we get too deep into the
process
um and watching those characters like
take
shape like they you know i would imagine
on the production end they're like all
right the ant-man looks great
now we can move forward with the story
this story is going to play better
because we know exactly what this cat's
going to look like
and we know what this cat looks like
because we got a bunch of artists to
draw in the real world ahead of time and
the nice thing too is like you said
is stan jack ditko all the source
material
is there for you to look at and
reinterpret and bring it into
like a current audience somebody can
look at that outfit and be like that is
really cool
it's it's just such a unique position
and it should be not like awards are
everything but it should be awarded
because it sounds like
you're you guys are a pretty crucial
step in the process
to the movies that we see and if the
filmmaker gets
awarded from time to time it seems like
the visionaries who are the
ones with their their the boots in the
dirt
first before anybody else first one off
the boat that's you guys
man heading into battle right away long
before you know a luxurious [ __ ] like
me come or somebody better than me comes
along and it's like
oh i know how to do this it's like you
guys have already kind of done it for
them
in two dimensions and sometimes three
with modeling
you guys are the new marvel bullpen yeah
yeah yeah it's definitely that kind of
model and that's why i definitely
appreciate like you know directors like
matt jackman when he
when i heard him mention me i was like
oh like that's i appreciate that i
appreciate that so much because
uh means a lot you know it's i mean
thank god he shouted you out because
otherwise we wouldn't have had you on
the [ __ ] show
and you're gold man like you're absolute
gold
you're in the nerve center like honestly
you're you stand you get to walk across
the hallway
and talk to the single most [ __ ]
important kevin on the planet the kevin
that must be saved at all cost
like a friend and [ __ ] like that how
dope is that
he is pretty cool he's pretty cool i i
pinch myself very often
it's a great [ __ ] job what do you
want to do in the future what's the goal
you eventually want to direct or you're
like nah [ __ ] that
i know a lot of a lot of artists have
that kind of i don't because i
i've seen it and i and i have so much
respect for you guys doing that because
that is
hard because i mean you're juggling
everything the marvel guys the marble
guys got it hard i got it easy
those cats
well the writing part is also hard too
right but um
i don't know i i'm i'm i'm an artist so
i definitely want to
i think the dream is to kind of create
something of my own
right but of course as as you know it's
like one of the hardest things to do
right especially when you have a family
trying to make a living all that kind of
stuff all the
real reality stuff but and and also when
the job
that you have is so fun most people when
they dream about doing something else
they're in the midst of something that
they can't stand
it sounds like you wake up every day and
you're like
you know yeah this is amazing
yeah there's definitely a little bit of
that um i yeah it's definitely the dream
job like it's definitely a dream job um
i
i can't complain it's it's a lot of work
i'm working weekends a lot i'm doing a
lot of
tough things but you know at the end of
the day i'm not complaining you know i'm
having a blast and i
i cannot believe like when i got hired
2010 we'd be talking you know here like
what is it 11 years later and we just
had you know end game that
used to be the number one movie of all
time just got dethroned
i knows but yeah and then now we're even
beyond endgame
you know i'm working on my almost 30th
film
at marvel studios so it's it's nuts it's
nuts
look at that man and you look young as
hell so i don't know how you
could do in 30 films for everything it's
asian blood
is that what it is give me some of that
take my age down
yeah black don't crack yellow don't
mellow there you go
what happens to white people we just get
old and die is that it
fade away tell us that part at the
beginning
sounded good andy you're doing the
lord's work and you're doing beautiful
beautiful stuff
i'm gonna guess and andy didn't say this
at all so if you're an internet site
don't pick this up and run with it
but i bet you we're looking at a man who
has probably drawn both dr
doom and galactus at one point or
another because we know they're in our
future ladies and gentlemen
i can't wait to say see what the unseen
heroes and villains
uh look like man and hopefully we've
come super tight and i become one of
those friends that you show your phone
to do you ever
show your friend like you can't you
can't text it or email it but are you
ever
in person with somebody and like show
them on your phone
no no i don't i don't you're a good
kid man that would that's more fear than
anything that's true
i'm sure that not everybody survived the
marvel vis dev department
because the drone strikes have taken out
some offenders
it'd be so hard not to be like look at
this nobody's here look at this
and show them what you that's scary
that's scary
um you are doing amazing work sir
continued success
thank you for coming on and hanging out
with us thank you so much
like i said in the beginning i'm a big
fan of both of you and uh thank you so
much for having me on your show i
appreciate it thank you big
fan of you man one piece of advice you
want to pass on for kids that want to do
what you're doing how do they do it
uh it's really pursuing your passion
it's putting in the hard work
so for if you want to become an artist
it is really building up your portfolio
so trying to find the specific areas
that you want to
pursue and and then doing your research
figuring out what
the people that you admire how they how
they got there what they did to get
there
and it's really putting in the work
because a lot of people say they have
passion but then
you know there's no proof in the pudding
the month goes by and they still haven't
done anything about it
you got to question that so you got to
put in the work um and do your due
diligence and
good things will happen wise words
everybody give it up for andy park andy
thank you for coming on fat man beyond
thank you more importantly
for that beautiful costume scarlet witch
is dignified
as well like she i i when she first
appeared on my division you know it's
not
it no longer means anything for me to
say i cried
but i was definitely crying and i
remember turning to my wife and i was
like
this is going to be embarrassing but i
turned my wife's out of the bed and i
was bawling as i saw her in the air for
the first time and i went
she looks like a disney princess
though you made a 50 year old man say
that to a woman who probably looked at
him it was like i'm never gonna [ __ ] you
again
that's the most embarrassing thing
you've ever said
thank you for that magical moment i
appreciate it thank you for telling me
that story i can retire now
where can people find you on the
internet andy yeah i'm going to track
you down
i'm on instagram twitter and youtube on
um
at andypark art andy park art
and tomorrow he's going to put up some
uh scarlet witch early art you're going
to get to see his designs man so check
them out
andy continued success man tell everyone
so much
we everyone when you go to work uh i
guess it's on zoom lately and [ __ ]
but next time you go into the office
when they let us get back to work and
[ __ ]
tell everyone i'm sure they know because
the show we say it almost every time
we're huge fans of what they're doing
over there you guys are doing the lord's
work keep [ __ ] doing it
keep doing it keep making these [ __ ]
drawings and making these movies until i
drop dead then after that do what you
want but i need this [ __ ]
i need it andy will do we'll do thank
you so much
give it up for andy everybody see you
later eddie see ya
bye god he was [ __ ] great man
more of that man more guests all the
time yes please
you know what i'm saying like people
like it's so like it's one thing to hear
about
from a director which was amazing having
mad on but hearing like
this like this position in particular
like it's it's a relatively new position
in the movie business now some people be
like they've been doing story birds for
years
yeah do you know what [ __ ]
storyboards look like little [ __ ]
sketches pencil sketches drawings and
[ __ ] having a whole division that
envisions
the movie like long before it gets made
you know and again it's not like
hey we're going to show the director
what this character looks like you know
stan and jack and all of marvel did that
years ago
so nobody's coming into this job going i
want to reinvent
it or if they are they're going to lose
that job so to have somebody who's
like i'm going to take these concepts
and bring them into the real world make
them work in a goddamn movie man that's
just
it's everything yeah i mean it's like
the
the one concept illustrator well a
couple but like
ralph mcquarrie was the first one that i
was ever really familiar with
you know and it's it's somewhat of a
similar job because it's like i've got
to somehow realize this idea
but what andy and his team are doing are
taking a thing that already exists
and reinterpreting it it's how does this
particular content is this character how
does this idea
work in the real world when it only ever
worked in two dimensions
and that's a different job and i think
it's a it's a different trick to have to
do
um so yeah power to him and power to
marvel for just saying we gotta staff up
give everybody a job keep them on staff
when you have talent you lock them down
and this is how we do that
that's how those movies stay as good as
they are you always wonder we sat there
going like well all right
the eternals is a bridge too far but we
know we're gonna [ __ ] fall in love
with and [ __ ] and it's because these ki
these cats keep their eye on the ball
man they're just not afraid to make it
better i think shackman or somebody was
saying like
if if they can make it like one percent
better
they'll do it right like it's all about
the
optim the most optimum best version of
the story that they could [ __ ] tell
me and they don't stop they don't rest
on their laurels
and they don't give you a sequel like
they'll sequalize but it's not like
hey it's like rocky too it's like rocky
but you know he
fights again every time they step
up like lately it's been pushing the
story
even further and further away like i'll
never forget
that moment at the end of [ __ ]
spider-man far from home
where you're like right on i know where
this shit's going he's going to be a
senior next year and
able to do the prom or senior trip or
some such [ __ ] like that
and all of a sudden like he's unmasked
and everybody knows who the [ __ ] he is
you're like what the heck
what happened i there goes my senior
year and [ __ ]
didn't see that coming not at all man
they quite like quicksilver
we don't see a lot of what's coming with
them so indeed so happy how did we get
andy how did that happen was that you
yeah andy reached out to me he was like
hey man i'm a big fan of the show
you know and you know wanted to thank
you again for having matt on and matt
said some lovely things and like if you
ever wanted to talk like
i'm here i said well yes talk now yeah
oh my god
come tell us everything um the you know
you know when i said like the words
doctor doom and galactus then andy was
like shut up
children you know he's probably
someone on that team is probably taking
a crack at doctor doom by now
probably um i just wanted to jump in uh
anybody who's watching andy socials are
in the youtube description if you want
to follow him and see more of his
artwork like we had on the show
um and also a lot of how nice how nice
was that did he
give you all that art yeah he sent that
all yesterday
um and then uh just a couple things from
chat
a lot of people said that this was our
best guest ever no disrespect to any of
our other guests but people loved it
um and that's [ __ ] dope man thank you
well thank you
fanny uh ardanex said um
he's able to explain it in a way that i
understand because i'm not in the
industry
he is so good at his job and at
communicating so i thought that was
pretty cool
that's high [ __ ] praise right there
man like not only is that
he's a classy guy but that's a classy
[ __ ] compliment that makes us look
good our fan base makes us look good
it does i mean we talked about it i
think after we had matt chachman on
and we were like you know we could we
could do more guests and like yeah we
can probably get movie stars or actors
or whatever because they're all doing pr
rounds
but getting like the people who make
this stuff
the people who don't get that sort of
like you know seth meyer
shine to come on and spend an hour with
us just talking about the craft and the
job and
and how they interpret it and how they
attack it like that's
to me way more interesting you know not
that a
shiny actor talking about their role
isn't interesting but nobody's talking
to these guys
and they've all got amazing stories to
tell and that feels
you know both uh good content quote
unquote but also important
like let's let people who make the stuff
tell us how they make it
telling you man marvel makes us happy
you know uh when they put out their
movies but they also make us happy
behind the scenes
so it's the new disney the happiest
place on earth is [ __ ] marvel
um all right so we don't have a new show
to talk about but i believe next week we
will definitely have a new show to talk
about and that being exactly
zack snyder's justice league um and then
after that it sounds like falcon and the
winter soldier will be our run for about
six episodes and stuff
but uh but today andy took the place of
what we've been doing historically since
wanda vision began which is like doing
deep dives on the
on the episodes we don't have any of
those but we don't tell you what we do
have
news god damn it we got news we got some
news
that's right news news news news
changing i wanted to get you to go why
can't you take a name
uh you know that was completely
unrehearsed kids i know it looked
i know it looked like we were you know
uh working
with choreographers but
right off the top of our heads mark
bernardin
i saw a piece last week where somebody
was like look i like matt shachman but
they didn't do the [ __ ] news and i
show up for the news
so to that one person i apologize
mark bernardin always brings us the news
and this week he's got a [ __ ] two
fistfuls of news i imagine
here's mark with the news mark what's
going on we have some news um
the one left over the holdover from last
week that we didn't get to cover
is that as i think we all might have
expected despite
the uh the increased rate of
vaccinations amongst
the american populace and the lowering
of infection rates and all that stuff
there is still not going to be a
comic-con in san diego this summer
um the there there may be some according
to the press release some
kind of in-person event in november on a
much smaller scale
but the comic-con that you know we all
know and love
the you know upwards of 200 000 people
descending on san diego's gaslamp
district
will not happen again until 2022.
now i'm not questioning science mark i'm
i wear two masks
so i'm fine with this decision because
it sounds like somebody responsible made
it
but um what do you think that's
predicated on because they're like look
even if we get to come back in july
it's going to be like quarter or half
capacity and
any [ __ ] gathering of even if it's
even if it was half capacity
you're talking about a hundred thousand
people even at a quarter capacity
you're talking about 50 000 people and
stuff so i guess it's just them being
responsible
i think so too i think you know
especially after the president's address
saying that like if we do all of the
right stuff
if we continue social distance and wear
our masks and get vaccinated when we can
we may be able to have small family
gatherings for the fourth of july
you know a backyard barbecue and that is
the far cry from you know the the sweaty
masses descending upon
a tiny city um and and like we've all
walked those halls
we have all seen pictures of what it
looks like and that is no way
to insulate yourself from from a virus
so i think that
sadly it would be a super spreader event
instantly yeah
the superist of super spreaders it would
be worse than your average you know
sporting event if you packed
the halls you know the stadium so that
would that would be the headlines and
all the papers the hacky headlines
super dash spreader comic con
kills no no heroes only villains
[ __ ] like that well it's a bummer two
years in a [ __ ] row man that's gonna
be weird but
that just means when we do go back it's
gonna be a party kids this is gonna be a
massive [ __ ] party let me tell you
something
personally when they said we're not
doing san diego comic con this year
i was sad but then i was happy because i
was like that means next year
i'll be able to fill hall h because
people will not have seen me for two
years they'll be like i'm desperate to
see
anybody even this [ __ ] idiot so
that's good for me mark i always have to
look at how it's gonna affect me
absence make the heart grow fonder so
yes and the wallet's a little looser
we will miss uh comic-con this year in
person but once again they're gonna do
it online and
uh we have started conversations uh with
the good
folks at netflix about uh our comic-con
online motu panel ooh
interesting because just like comic-con
motu is coming and just like comic-con
you can watch it on your tv
you ain't got to go to it it's coming to
you
whether you want it or not i think i
said it before but bear mccreary just
crushing on the score and i heard the
score for mark's whole episode which is
beautiful
and then i heard four and five as well
like this dude is doing
stellar work jeff's kiss as we say on
the show
thanks to somebody who misunderstood us
three weeks ago yes
jeff's kids and the t-shirts are coming
kids trust me
um but yes jeff's kiss indeed on to the
news indeed
on to the further newest of new news um
uh you know how these giant studios
conglomerates
uh massive companies will always have
sort of they call them investor
calls where it'll be hey
everybody who's got you know massive
shares of stock in our company
come and listen to us tell you what's
happening what's basically what you're
buying
with your massive investment and so at t
had one of those investor calls
you know we had one last year when
disney just like unzipped their fly and
showed us
you know months and months and months of
star wars content marvel content and
what have you
so at t part of their big presentation
is
look at all the dc stuff that's coming
down the pike um
we knew most of it except for one thing
that they're making a zatanna
tv show i heard this on twitter this
week sorry i heard
i've read something because zatanna was
trending
and as a longtime fan i was like why
apparently they're doing a whole [ __ ]
show that's a no-brainer to me
yeah lady magician most powerful
magician
in the dc universe like done and done
is that all the shows that they're doing
that is that is their entire slate
of both movies and tv all right so let's
go through this man
uh black adam is at the top we knew that
was coming harley quinn exists
superman and lois static shock we know
is coming
blue beetle we just found about uh last
week and stuff
batgirl is a new thing correct i mean
it's it's a new thing that's also an old
thing
like there had been a version of batgirl
that joss whedon was going to do
at some point before he dropped out and
they had brought a new writer on
i think christina hobson who had done
bumblebee
had been engaged to do batgirl um but i
think now that it's legit on a schedule
quote unquote it is more firm than it
had been
before um but no they haven't said who's
in charge or who's doing it yet haven't
they
no no no no no more details beyond
here it is up on a screen what um uh jc
throw that chart back up again just so
we can
finish it off um peacemaker we know
they're in production on that already
and that's coming relatively soon after
suicide squad happens on hbo max
green lantern they announced that for
hbo max we knew that aquaman two we knew
was coming
there's the flash symbol which i guess
is for the movie flash correct
correct uh teen titans go suicide squad
which we knew was coming back wheels is
the
kids show about all the vehicles that
hang out as buddies
uh the batman that's uh matt reeves
movie we can't wait to see there's
zatanna
what's next that is that's super what is
that
oh because this is their final season of
supergirl absolutely
uh shazam sequel's up there what's next
to shazam
uh that's batman oh i can't see the font
and that's happening already what's
under us in the corner
cause i saw us and i was like we're on
the slate this is amazing on the
on the street it's interesting because
there's two suicide squads up here
oh well the suicide squad is
uh james gunn's movie so i wonder what
suicide
squad is are they doing a cartoon um i'm
not entirely sure
i mean that the two separate logos is
slightly confusing but
maybe it's a cartoon maybe it's a live
action show
i mean then again peacemaker is also a
live-action spin-off from suicide squad
so maybe suicide squad is a gift that
we'll keep on giving
to hbo max it's currently their avengers
more or less
yeah uh the gcpd was the uh
show that's the spin-off of matt reeves
correct correct
then with the what were the other three
i'm sorry jc bring it back
um dmz is that the rosario dawson thing
that's the rosario doesn't thing
directed by
ava's doing that what is gotham knights
gotham knights is a video game i believe
um unless they're also spinning that
into a series but i think it was it was
very much kind of like proto birds of
prey
in a way uh superhero high
we i've heard about that and then the
super pets
kind of speaks for itself um so that's
yeah that's kind of exciting there's
some cool stuff to look forward to there
there's some cool stuff and like
zatanna show mated with the news that
we're
getting a constantine constantine show
um
yeah that's not that's not up on the
board though
not up on the board um which is odd
given that we knew it was coming jc get
rid of that board [ __ ] that board we're
done with that board
yeah we want to see us but um
but there's definitely the version of
you know they're building out the
justice league dark
um in a real way and you get zatanna
you get constant time you know i'm sure
that there's a couple
two three more kind of in deep
development over bad robot
you'd probably want swamp thing in the
mix as well potentially you could get
the demon in there if you wanted the
demon
gone gone the form of man rise form a
veterinarian
yes the um the alternate suicide
chat is saying is a video game done by
the
people who did the arkham series yes
that's right the one that for a while
people thought was they thought uh
pizarro was gonna be the villain because
it was a
image of superman but he's just the
target but yes
it's a video game that makes sense right
boy they got a full slate they got a lot
of cool stuff
i like they're doing the marble thing
about putting up all their like this is
everything we're doing here's all our
squares
looking excited yeah i'm in i'm in i'll
watch it all
right even super pets even the back
wheels i'll probably watch that too
you know there will be another night you
need to fill four hours on hbo max
nothing nothing's ever gonna i'm telling
you bro
watching that from friday at one in the
morning till five in the morning like i
honestly thought i was like i'll [ __ ]
watch an hour and go to sleep
i was riveted and and it's it's so
vastly different from a marvel movie and
then not to lower one and raise the
other
stuff they're just two completely
different beasts um but marvel movies
feel like
absolute movies to me um whereas
this felt like uh for lack of a better
description this felt like a film
zack snyder's justice league felt like a
four-hour
film a meditation on super
heroes and super heroics um i can't wait
for you to watch it because i want to
hear what you have to think
yeah it's coming soon kids it's coming
on thursday thursday
march leave four hours aside for the
snyder cut
i feel bad for hbo max man they might
crash
everyone's going to hit them so [ __ ]
hard as of midnight
that twitter [ __ ] handle you know all
the twitter fans oh my god
um all right what else we got um
there's some some movement part of the
pun in the flash
casting and that the flash is losing a
dad
and gaining a mom billy crudup is
dropping out of the movie that is being
directed by andy machetti
because of shooting conflicts with the
morning show the apple
tv plush show that he's already on
um and there's been no replacement for
him so far but
they're adding barry allen's mother who
you know to a certain degree you know
may or may not make it that far into
said movie if they are indeed doing
flashpoint she
she's a main character right you know in
flashpoint of course most of us know
this but for those that don't
flashpoint is a story uh of barry allen
the flash
um whose mom had been killed when he was
a kid
and maybe by his dad but really it was
by
uh the backwards flash professor zoom
um um i don't know if he was eobard
thawne in the comics or not i forget
which one
but regardless his mom was dead
and then one day barry in the in the uh
the storyline that jeff johns wrote
like decided why don't i just go back
and save her
like i have the ability to do this so
i'm gonna go save my mom
and he does and it destroys the [ __ ]
universe everything gets incredibly
[ __ ] up
so if they are doing um that storyline
as they've
intimated or it's been intimated online
uh
hiring a mom is absolutely essential
um you know i'm not i'm nobody's career
agent or coach
but i can't believe that [ __ ] crude
up wasn't like you know what
like make it work like that's a good gig
man but you know obviously him playing
barry's dad in justice league for zach
made sense because him and zach had
worked together on watchmen he was the
original dr manhattan
so maybe you know his loyalties were
more with zach and he was like look
i got my other show so you guys find
another flash i would just like to put
out there
that if they want a somewhat youthful
looking dad for the flash one who
dresses like a 12 year old
professionally
i i've acted in movies mark i'm also an
actor you know
i've played i've saved the role of
cylobop for many years but i can also
speak dialogue as needed right here
here's my audition barry slow down
there you go how come how come i can't
have that [ __ ] part man i'm i'm
crewed up good
who's the mom did they did they yes that
would be my version
that very sick who did they cast as mom
did they say
yes a woman named maribel verdu who was
in e2 mama tambien
and pan's labyrinth is playing uh is
playing barry's mom
and as you said kirsty clemens has
locked in her deal to come back as
as iris west that's good for her i'm
sure like you know
she got cut out of justice league
originally and stuff so i'm sure she was
like well i guess it's all over and now
somebody called her up and they were
like no you're in let's go so much let's
go to work
it's good news good for her indeed um
speaking of casting
um the live-action powerpuff girls pilot
at the cw has announced their cast i saw
this
i saw this oh and we got pictures of
them what are their names pictures and
everything
um chloe bennett from uh agents of
shield has been cast as blossom
um dove or dovey cameron i'm not sure
um has been cast as buttercup and uh
let's see jana perot has been cast
as um
buttercup buttercup yes um
the one girl who's playing bubble she
was a disney kid right the dove girl
yeah yeah she comes on maddie and the
descendants
and i think she has a recording career
if i remember correctly or something
like that one of those disney kids who
sings maybe i'm wrong
um the agents of shield i've met chloe
and talked to her and interviewed her
and stuff like that
uh and who's the third girl where's she
come from i don't know um she's a
broadway kid she was in um
she was in uh the atlantis morissette
musical jagged little pill
oh right on and she was set to join the
cast of hamilton
before the pandemic shut down broadway
oh she was going to work in the actual
hamilton not like some film diversion
yeah yeah so um but this this i think
will be her
her big live-action screen debut could
you imagine like uh hey man you're gonna
be in hamilton you're like oh my god i'm
a broadway person that means the world
they're like sorry broadway shut down
but we got something else for you all
night
did you ever think about being a
powerpuff girl um i look forward to
watching the show at least give it a try
it seems funny to me i'm in yeah
i mean as well and then there's a little
tiny um adjunct story that broke this
week
that craig mccracken who's a creator of
the original cartoon network powerpuff
girls
said that he had pitched an idea to
warner
brothers for a for a crossover episode
where the joker came to the city of
townsville
um according to him on twitter says i
wanted to do a ppg episode with a joker
the animated series version
came to townsville and the mayor was so
star trek with a famous villain in town
that he wouldn't let the girls stop him
but warner brothers said no when we
asked
why i don't know aren't they all owned
by the same company
yeah like that would have been so
[ __ ] cool
they and if they were doing the animated
series they would have mark hamill doing
the voice they would have our joker
i'm sure that's exactly what craig
mccracken wanted and one of our
brothers had to piss on his parade i
love
the powerpuff girls uh my kid was at the
sweet spot
for appreciation of powerpuff girls
growing up she still has powerpuff girls
artwork original artwork in her uh
bedroom and stuff hanging on the wall
but my one of my favorite [ __ ]
powerpuff girl moments in the world was
in the powerpuff girls
movie where um they're they're being
forced to recite the alphabet
and uh like shit's going wrong for them
all the time the teacher's like hey
give us the alphabet and they're like a
b c d
e and then the roof collapses on them or
something like that and then afterwards
they go f
it's a pretty tight joke man in a
[ __ ] side joke
that's a really solid joke that craig
mccracker kid he was all talent and
still
is and stuff he did that other what was
it the home for
wayward monsters or whatever the [ __ ] it
was called yeah dr
foster's or foster's home for imaginary
some things
well done almost we between the two of
us we got close we we got there
um but that what a [ __ ] what a missed
opportunity that would have that was
so much fun like that that's the thing
that you hope
you'd be able to do under the sort of
corporate shingle of warner brothers
i got an idea we use the power
the power of social media and [ __ ]
release the mccracken cut
release the mccracken yes
i like your draft better than mine you
win
release the mccracken
what else we got um disneyland is back
baby
finally man i got one of them kids that
lives for [ __ ] disneyland and [ __ ]
she's been every month she's been like
any word any word because she's in
dallas
i'm like no and if you really want to go
to a disney [ __ ] florida's open go
there and [ __ ]
but she you know my kid grew up out and
mostly out in los
angeles and from a young age we she was
a disney kid
we had season passes i would bring her
all the time i spent
an inordinate amount of time at
disneyland like as an adult
um and you know that was fine by me
because that's right up my alley and
[ __ ]
but uh she you know at a certain point
it's kind of sad to admit it's real cats
in the cradle but at a certain point
like after i'd been to disney like
[ __ ] 30 times
you know i was just like well you know
why don't you go with nan and pop
and stuff like that kid never lost her
interest in it i guess i just got old
and fat and i didn't want to walk around
a theme park and [ __ ] like that
but the kid just to this day it's like
you know
her literal happy place like it is the
happiest place she buys all the
marketing and [ __ ] as well as all the
toys
but she don't get to buy the season pass
no more they did away with it
i know i mean i'm sure there will be
some other version for them to take a
giant chunk of money from you at once
um but i think they're modulating it so
that they
they can just take more money from you
i'm in no rush to go back although i do
want i did not get to see star wars land
yet
me neither but i'll tell you right now
if they announce that
avengers campus is open you can't keep
me from that place
i'll be there in a heartbeat man um well
on july 20 it was supposed to be july
2020
um it's now set to open later this year
um the park itself will start welcoming
guests in late april
so it seems like they spent a [ __ ] ton
of money building that stuff
they're not not going to let you in
that's that means we're going to be able
to walk the avengers campus probably by
the end of the year
jc's on what do you want jc
or he's not on he's muted do you think
all three of us should go down
and um just hold that thought right
there because i think all three of us
should always go down my friend
thank you i could live stream the whole
thing from my phone
so we could do like a fat man beyond
visit galaxy's edge and avengers campus
i a i'm so down for that b they'll let
us live stream in the park
we did it uh for scum and villainy when
they opened the new galaxy's edge
trading post at downtown disney a couple
weeks back
so i mean maybe right what if we just
say oh we're taking home movies
and beyond the cantina i meant oh yeah
road trip
i'm all for it man you make it happen
i'll [ __ ] come out and see what we
can do
that'd be fun i'd be very fun when it
reopens in april it'll be at 15 capacity
and for california residents only
with no indoor dining and limits on
indoor rides as the covered rates
continue to drop theme park capacity
will rise to 25
then 35 percent then at some point they
will just start rolling back all of
those restrictions
i might have to change my vote mark
because at fifteen percent
that's the way to go to disneyland like
you wanna cost us four times as much
worth it worth it take all my money just
let me go on the rides more than once
and let me do them all
um this would be the way to go to
galaxy's edge pay the premium
and [ __ ] deal with only 15 percent of
the crowd that'd be badass
jc jc banff back in
show that special effect there's the
money there's the budget that's the my
that's the hbo max money
right there um you went to galaxy's edge
correct
i have been uh several times so by the
indication
several indicates that you enjoyed it
the first time correct it's
um it's really really cool uh
i mean you guys have to go seeing the
millennium falcon and going on
i mean walking on the millennium falcon
and it's you know what's that like well
okay mark going on the millennium
and having it wrap around you you know
it's not just like a set
that's one wall it's it's 360
and then you walk in it's so crazy it's
really really
like mind-blowing i really kicked myself
when the quarantine
like uh went into full effect where i
was like i can't believe
i'm locked out of it and i didn't
[ __ ] rush to go i just you know took
it for granted i was like well let's
open it'll be there and i'll go when
things calm down and then things never
calmed down they got very excitable and
disneyland went away
i think we said that like every week for
a month and a half on the podcast like
we'll go when the crowds die down but
be careful what you wish for mark
because the crowds did calm down
just far too much far too much uh what
else we got
um our last story for the evening is my
favorite story of the week
is that um your friend and mine
elizabeth banks is set to make her
directorial
follow-up to charlie's angels with a new
thriller for universal
this movie will be called cocaine bear
excellent title
i'm in i'm buying a ticket i don't even
know the story i do know the story i've
heard about it online
yes um but it turns out that the title
is a little description of an actual
event
which is during a drug run from colombia
a narcotics officer turned smuggler
dumped 40 kilos of cocaine over
chattahoochee natural forest where the
entire hall was devoured by a bear
the body was found by the authorities
who declared the cause of death as
perhaps the single biggest drug overdose
in recorded history
naturally the locals dubbed him pablo
escobar
i didn't know that that's that should be
the name of the movie
that's adorable pablo escobar let's be
honest cocaine bear is a [ __ ] hot
title
it's an amazing title it is a it's a
snakes on the
on a plane level title for sure and so
if if elizabeth banks can make a comedy
that earns the title cocaine bear which
who the [ __ ] knows what the cocaine bear
was up to
after it ingested that much coke and
before it died of an overdose
gold i um i'm sure
the uh the peta and aspca people are
going to be very happy about this motion
picture
i'm sure they will have nothing to
nothing to worry about
don't breathe don't bring your kids and
confuse this with winnie the pooh ladies
and gentlemen winnie the pooh
is an addict of honey yes this this bear
apparently
is it's down for the for the white yogi
bear really likes picnic baskets
cocaine in bear like season else
entirely
he'll he'll he'll cut or kill ranger
smith
for that picnic basket they'll be a
serious boo-boo
and it'll be a murder in yellowstone
park jelly stone park
jelly stone park um that is all the news
we have my friend
all the news that's fit to bring give it
up for mark bernard he brought you the
goddamn [ __ ] news
after no news last week all news this
week
indeed uh jc come join us and tell us is
there anybody that wants to know
anything
i didn't get a chance to follow along on
uh uh the chat this week and stuff and
i've noticed sometimes people like that
some people
some people like me reading the chat but
some people like stop reading [ __ ]
chat and [ __ ] like that
so there's been no chat so i don't know
what the tenor of the room was other
than the fact that
jc told us that uh the cats everyone
liked andy and thought he was a great
cast
how has chat been jason uh chess been
great i haven't had to block or delete
any comments today which i know now that
i say that
it's gonna be horrible but yeah here it
comes okay
here comes trump 2024 because you opened
your [ __ ] mouth yeah
way to go here's the clip
uh what questions you got for us sir you
picked uh one of three yet
let's see um
caped madman wanted to know uh what is
the greatest
non-superhero comic book movie that
hasn't been made yet
non-superhero non-dc marvel what's the
greatest comic book movie
that has yet to be made mage
the hero discovered by matt wagner it's
the update of the arthurian legend
um yes kevin matchstick finds out that
he is the pendragon reincarnated
um he hangs out with uh a wizard a
merlin offshoot whose name
escapes do you remember the name of the
wizard merv i think it is
it might be merv um and then the lady of
the lake
um the you know the the girl who holds
his bat
her name escapes me as well it's been a
while since i read it and i remember
they're all fighting the umber sprite
and i remember like the final issue is
he has to climb the tower
to fight the umber sprite and stuff it
is so absolutely wonderful and i spoiled
it the way i laid it out there i'm like
he's the pen dragon
you read mage by matt wagner and you
didn't know what was going on until that
one issue where
merv was finally like you are the
[ __ ] pen dragon it was so goddamn
metal and [ __ ]
but it was called the hero discovered
mage the hero discovered then he did
sequels like
mage the hero defined and stuff like
that but mage i can't believe it still
hasn't been done came close a few times
but it still hasn't been done one of the
best non-marvel non-dc comic books
that can be brought to life second close
second
and this is a personal fave but i doubt
anyone's thinking about making this but
they [ __ ] should
would be grim jack which was a first
comic that was written by john ostrander
who created the suicide squad with kim
yael
and one of the greatest [ __ ] comic
books i've ever read in my life about
john gaunt
our hero grimjack who owns a
interdimensional bar in the city of
sinister
which merges and links up with all
any place in the world um over time it's
just constantly in dimensional ship
so sometimes new york was right next to
sinister
and sometimes gotham for lack of a
better description would be next to the
signature
um and it was a story of a mercenary
like you know easy to do
move tv very episodic and stuff
but i have stolen from that uh story
line so many times
most memorably on my green arrow run of
quiver
in that storyline ollie queen spoilers
dies and eventually goes to heaven and
stuff and
finds himself there because he's already
died and
his dead earlier version of himself is
like i'm not going back
there's no way i'm going back to earth
this is [ __ ] amazing i like it here
and he has to make the choice to leave
paradise to save his friends because
somebody's reanimated his corpses
killing all of his friends
so he has to like because he's he loves
his friends so much he oh
i love this book he he leaves heaven
and i i stole that for green arrow like
you know because i can't think of a more
noble thing for a hero to do it's like
you've earned your just reward
this is your eternal reward and yet to
make the choice to leave [ __ ]
paradise behind
on behalf of the living when it's not
your problem anymore
i love that note i will play that note
in every [ __ ] song i possibly can man
and i got it
from grim jack so i'd love to see that
be a series one day
mark um two things come to mind
i think much of
ed brubaker's uh image comic work
especially criminal
and the books is sort of his his kind of
crime opera initiative
is all just so good it's so ripe for for
adaptation you know he's he's writing
our modern noir on comic book form in a
way that that you know few people have
done and have been able to do as well
the work that he does with sean phillips
um i think would be great but i think
the one that still surprises me that
hasn't been done
is art spiegelman's mouse yeah very true
you know i feel like a it's it's a it's
an impenetrable
bulletproof undeniable classic of the
form um
it's incredibly emotional and heartfelt
and to be able to sort of
recontextualize
the the story of the holocaust using
cats and
mice um make it the sort of thing that
you could use that to tell to teach
children
about that level of intolerance in a way
that isn't quite as
frightening i think as say shimlu's list
is
but still carries all the power um
you know and i think a really smart
animated version of that story
um would not just do well but be very
very important
um and i don't know why it hasn't been
done i don't know if it's an art
spiegelman doesn't want it to be adapted
or if the powers that be
all think there's money to be made in it
i'm not sure but i think that's
it's sitting there just waiting to to
win somebody a bunch of awards
and more than that do like a really good
do a mitzvah
for the world um so a mouse
excellent pull [ __ ] that was a great
ball man um
all right there's one down jc bam back
in here
and give us some more okay um
if you guys had wanda's powers
who would you bring back for a moment to
watch
tv with and what tv show would you watch
my dad and i'd watch bowling for dollars
like i did when i was a kid he would lay
in front of the tv a big old box tv set
picture tube console tv set when tv was
a piece of the furniture kids
like and your parents went out of the oh
this is a nice tv we can only put nice
things on the tv like a scale can go on
top
on top of a doily and on the weekends i
was made to dust
the tv and stuff it was a central uh
figure in in our
feng shui of our living room so my
father would lay on the floor
uh looking at the tv like you know
this like laying back watching tv like
that
and i would it's going to sound dirty
that i meant it i would t-bone my dad
um i would lay the other way so he's
this way and i would lay this way
with my head on his stomach and i'd
watch
uh the bowling for dollar show as a kid
which is you know not a show it's
[ __ ]
it's literally bowling on tv and [ __ ]
um if i if i had the mind stone yeah
i would do that again when my when i
went into the hospital in philadelphia
where my old man uh he had a massive
heart attack i was at the wizard world
con in philly and i'd done like a q a
show and
my mom and my dad and my brother and my
sister were all in town and so they all
came to the show and stuff
and then we went out to eat and my wife
was with me jennifer and my sister's
husband eric was there my brother's
husband uh
jerry was not there he was the only one
missing but we had a great night sitting
around [ __ ] and talking
[ __ ] like you know three kids trying
to make their parents laugh and you
could tell
my parents was just like we did some
[ __ ] [ __ ] look we we raised a goddamn
family and they all turned out
[ __ ] okay and they're all got love in
their lives and [ __ ] like that
and the old man was eating like [ __ ]
filet mignon and sneaking cheesecake and
drinking manhattans and stuff like that
uh great night fantastic night and
kissed him on the head put him in a cab
with mom and dad
with mom and my sister and uh he went
back to the apartment that he was
staying
with my um with my sister she was in
town
for like a month to work on uh some
stuff with her kids and stuff because
she normally lives overseas
and uh the next morning i had the phone
call from my brother like you gotta get
down to the hospital and i was like oh
why
he's like dad's in the hospital and dad
was always in the hospital he's always
in poor health he's diabetic and stuff
but uh donald was like no get down here
now
and i went to the hospital on i think
it's cedar
or oak is one of the tree names in the
philadelphia area
and went to the emergency room and
walked in and saw something that still
chills me to this day
my mother like praying
desperately you know i'd seen my mother
prayer my whole life were raised
catholic and [ __ ] like that
but i never seen my mom like pray
as if there was like a gun to her head
like she was like oh god jesus please no
don't do this jesus please please got
like just like
[ __ ] out loud and passionate and
urgent didn't matter
she was not going like people might hear
this she didn't give a [ __ ] she was just
nobody else was in the world except her
and you know
my dad um who was in the emergency room
and so my brother i see my brother when
my mom is saying all this and i looked
at my brother
because my mom's looking in the other
direction and we make eye contact and
i'm like like what the [ __ ] is going on
the dad's always in the hospital
and it never occurred to me that dad was
in the hospital
but wasn't in the hospital anymore you
know i just didn't think my old man was
he was always sick but never seemed like
he was dying
and my brothers shook his head like this
and [ __ ] no
look i [ __ ] went to the desk and i
was like donald smith and
and they were like come back with us and
they brought me into a room
and uh my dad was like lying on the
stretcher and just like
still as a [ __ ] raincoat like there
was no life there whatsoever he was
still intubated had the tube in his
mouth and [ __ ] from there trying to save
his life
but there he was just motionless like
dead and uh i'd never of course seen my
father dead before
but i was uh this was 18 years ago or
something like that so i was in my early
30s and stuff
but this i knew this was my absolute
last opportunity in the world i'm gonna
try to get through this without breaking
down kids but
um they left me alone with them and he
was laid out
and for the last time ever in this world
and probably
you know vastly inappropriate at age 30
something
i put my head on my dad's stomach and it
certainly wasn't the same because a
there's no bowling for dollars and b he
was [ __ ] pretty dead
so given the chance to bring somebody
back i'd bring back bald man and
watch tv with him i'm sure he'd be like
why the [ __ ] are you wasting this minute
watching bowling for dollars and i'm
like cause i'm sentimental dad
and he'll be like oh my god i [ __ ] up
as a father but yes
i'd bring him back that's why if you've
not seen the
pixar movie onward
did you see it yet mark oh yeah no we
talked about it
that [ __ ] the end of the movie
destroyed me
still does even thinking about it i'm
getting like real emotional and having
to push it down
so [ __ ] beautiful there's something
about you know they say
fathers and daughters and stuff like
that but like you know
i didn't have a son so i don't know what
the father and son thing
was i was but i was a son and i know
there's [ __ ] connective
tissue like that and so watching onward
i was just like a
[ __ ] mess who would you bring back um
don't say like elvis or some [ __ ] [ __ ] i
just gave a really great answer
i know i don't know and i don't i i
there there's no way to
top that so i can't um and also i'm i'm
lucky enough to have both of my parents
um you're blessed my friend blessed
yeah my wife lost her mother
when she was 15 i think in a car
accident
and so i've never got to meet her i know
i've never met
my wife's mother my mother-in-law you
know my kids have never met
you know that grandparent um
so i think i'd bring her back you know
because i would like to know
who she is what she's like what what she
wanted for her kids
also a huge gift to your mom a huge gift
to my mom and i don't know what you'd
like to watch i'd let her choose
you know because ultimately it doesn't
matter what you're watching the what
you're watching
is the excuse to sit there sometimes
most of the time in silence with
somebody and so
let her choose whatever she wants to
watch i don't care
like i just kind of want to be there
that's beautiful that reminds me of the
luther vander song
dance with my father oh i can't i can't
even say it out loud without
getting real [ __ ] emotional i love
that song uh we
to move on to something else before i
start crying god damn it
jc banff in here and get us out of this
emotional mess
i won't i won't share mine then no go
ahead do you you have to do that
when my mom so my mom had brain cancer
four years ago
um and i'm gonna try to get through it
also uh
i and she and my dad split in 2010 so
she has not had a lot of people to hug
her
and be physical with um
and uh this will be hard um
i crawled into her hospital bed
i don't know i mean she was in and out
of the hospital all year
um i crawled into bed with her and we
put on
uh magnificent seven or no great escape
sorry the great escape and she used to
watch that
with her father who passed away from
cancer
also and we watched the first half of
great escape until she fell asleep and i
just lied there i watched the rest of
the movie so
i would go back and watch the second
half
of great escape with my mom it's
beautiful
can't believe you weren't going to share
that
i got through it sort of you did that
you did i didn't you [ __ ] prick
i kept my story shorter i know but
at the moment you were like i have one i
was like i know exactly what this is
gonna be i didn't know exactly but i
knew it would definitely be your mom
oh my god that's beautiful all right too
much [ __ ] beauty going on let's get
back to
let's get back to the comic books people
punching each other in the face
uh okay so let's get let's get
imaginative with this
um if they could have one fictional
character
on this podcast who would it be
obviously it'd be kevin feige if it was
a real person
who i was going to say he could pick
another kevin
yes and let's let's be honest we're not
sure that kevin feige isn't fictional at
this point nobody can be that good at
their [ __ ] job
this sounds like a made-up character you
know i've never met him so far it's all
hearsay
yeah look they got lots of guys in
baseball hats out there
i think this guy is an algorithm he's a
program
and they put up an image of somebody and
[ __ ] because nobody could be as smart
and as talented as this [ __ ] guy
um who would i like as a guest as a
are they a guest or a third uh
poor fourth you're technically the third
hmm
are you gonna lose your job if we hire
this
i guess mark you go first
a fictional character on the podcast
um
i kind of want yoda
um but then i also want the watcher
oh watcher gives good content nothing
but content
he's got nothing but stories he's seen
it all
um yeah i think i'm gonna go with the
watcher i'm gonna go with the watcher
let me see um
i think well bruce wayne if you
interview him you're not getting batman
no matter how hard you try
right so you know and who wants to talk
to a rich person
and batman is a man of few words so
batman's not going to be a good guest
i mean superman would be pretty
interesting he's friendly and he's also
from another world and [ __ ] but he's one
of the most covered celebrities on the
planet so it's like what new are you
going to unearth from [ __ ] superman
like kryptonite's still a problem yeah
um let's see um
um tony stark is interesting
but although maybe it's that robert
downey jr is interesting so maybe we
just want to get robert downey jr on the
show is that possible
can we get that happening we can always
try we can't even get [ __ ] victor
garber i don't think you're gonna get
[ __ ]
robert downey jr garber shits on this
show man
rdj he's never coming our way um
you know this is not a very original or
clever answer but you get a lot of
content out of darth vader you just have
to
be very careful and not piss him off
otherwise he's like
[Music]
and you're like ah that's it for fat man
beyonce um
come back next week but we're not yeah
say five times
um oh you know i think i might want
go kermit the frog ooh
i think kermit hi ho hi ho hi-ho
tell me kermit why are there so many
songs about rainbows i'll tell you
he's like well mark it ain't easy being
green
kermit also think about how many people
kermit has met
doing the muppet show and the muppet
movies
be like what's mark hamill like kermit
well that's true
he's kind of he's he's got in him you
get him as a guest but he's kind of like
a dick cavett
so he can tell you stories about all the
people he's ever spoken to
i'm sure he's like johnny carson
or dick i like that that's a good call
i'm gonna throw one up that's uh
trying to think of the things i
absolutely have loved and there's some
people i'm like ooh
but then i realize they're real people
not fictional characters
i would like to you know be amazing to
have chief brody
from jaws as a guest and have him tell a
first-hand account
of [ __ ] jaws through his point of
view and [ __ ] like that
talk about how they smell like fish and
my biggest question would be like all
right you [ __ ] kill
jaws and then you guys have to swim back
to shore
but there's all that chum in the water
because the dead shark you don't think
more other sharks are coming
were you scared to swim home
like at what point like did you figure
out like i guess you know we gotta swim
home through the credits [ __ ]
that's what i'd wanna know and i'd also
wanna know
why a guy who's afraid of the water
moved to an island but so did his wife
so yeah also his wife must have been
like you think he like walks in
and he's like soaking wet and she's like
you [ __ ] missed dinner
again three nights you've been out and
now you've come back soaking wet [ __ ]
you go out in the car
i wonder what it would be like i wonder
if you could get anything interesting
from thomas and martha wayne
you know and like because ultimately
what you want is what what hopes do you
have for your son
you know what what would you like that
would be
that would be a cruel interview knowing
what we then know happens to their son
yeah like what were their initial hopes
for young people
i think bruce will be a doctor and a
philanthropist and [ __ ] like that
like lady lady no he's not yeah all i
want for him is to find the thing that
he's good at
and to just embrace it and you know i
hope it's something that helps people
i hope it's something that that makes
the most use of his position as a wayne
in gotham city but
i just i also hope that he just like
finds him happiness and gets married has
a family
and you know goes on to maybe run for
mayor or something he could do great
things in the city
or could you imagine she's just like uh
like um
having them both on instantly they get
into some court of owls talk and [ __ ]
like that
will you find out the dirty history of
gotham and [ __ ] and how batman ties into
it
would that be hot um that is a good call
man
riddler might be good too but annoying
because
you can't get it you can't get a
straight answer out of them you're like
hey man so
how old are you riddle me this you know
oh [ __ ]
always catchphrase this is a ten minute
segment we don't have all [ __ ] money
yeah did you see andy andy's interview
for heaven's sakes andy park why don't
you be more like him
riddle me this when is an andy not a
park and you know gosh shut the [ __ ] up
then he pulls out his question mark gun
and shoots you in the face and i'll be
honest with you mark
you get shot with a fake in the face
with a question mark gun it hurts just
as much as the real gun
it's just shaped funny why does this
hurt so much
yeah why because of that extra power to
loop around and come out
what great questions man and that saved
us from a real [ __ ] tear fest as well
indeed uh what about you j.c you got one
uh somebody in chat just said they'd
like ralph boner
on the show just like ralph
how does it feel to be named after the
boner from growing baines or
ralph and also actually quicksilver
or ralph what was it like when everyone
was sure you were mephisto
um that's all we got for him that's all
the content we got
that's what we got we gave him a hell of
a show i feel like
ladies and gentlemen you have a good
time of course you did man this is your
happy time
every week we gather together and have a
good time talking about the [ __ ]
that fills us with goddamn joy uh we
like to thank our guest
andy park who just crushed it um gave us
some
inside dope and we got to learn about a
position that maybe not everyone knew
about before this uh podcast began so we
might have
learned a thing or two together man uh
give it up for
jc who keeps us happening in the cyber
world but it looks like
sounds like according to what he said if
he came in late
uh it sounds like this coming villainy
cantina will be opening
soon kids so uh yes very soon and it
feels like by
the end of the first week in april maybe
second week in april
we might be able to have a live show
with some people in the room and that
place is spaced out as long as everyone
wears their mask then you ain't got to
be worried about that place there are
like private [ __ ] booths there's
walls
between everybody let's set up for
[ __ ] quarantine and covet [ __ ]
so hopefully we'll be doing this live
and in person at this coming villainy
cantina
uh very very soon but even without being
there uh jc is jc still
make sure that you uh see and hear us so
give it up for jc and
uh and give it up for the man uh of many
words the man of many wisdoms
uh the writer in the group ladies and
gentlemen i'm a writer he's a writer for
heaven's sake
give it up for uh my clever clever
co-host man the man who knows all
sees all captures the news and has
insightful questions
great mark bernard thank you sir thank
you and also let's give it up to our
sponsor for this week
zack snyder's justice league coming soon
to hbo max
this thursday at midnight
i loved it i love the kids and nobody
wants to hear this and [ __ ]
or maybe some do but some people are
probably tired of this but
i'm sure somebody will be like well did
he cry was it that good
i am happy to report that there is a
moment in the movie that
did bring me to tears and it happens
within the first hour of the movie and
it's a wonder woman moment and it's
something that
didn't exist in the justice league that
was released theatrically
which by the way warner brothers
says is canon like they're saying zack
snyder's justice league is its own
separate thing
but that the josh justice league is
canon to their universe which i'm like
big mistake big mistake why would you do
that
uh snyder cut is coming folks zack
snyder's justice league is its official
title
and it's coming on thursday wednesday
night at uh
eight o'clock uh east eastern or
pacific i can't remember which you can
find it online it's it'll be on zach's
socials on
uh youtube channel i think hbo mac's
youtube channel i'm not sure but
we shot a whole red carpet premiere
special in which uh
i interview zach sit down and talk to
him shows all sorts of
footage behind the scenes some spoiler
stuff and then as soon as it ends
there's a live component to it at the
end where
me and zach come on live so you can
literally ask questions and stuff
as soon as that part's over bam snyder
cut
just debuts on hbo max you're not going
to want to miss it thank you to the good
folks at hbo max and zack snyder's
justice league
uh for sponsoring this episode of batman
beyond let's be honest man they were
getting it anyway we're going to be
talking about them regardless
but we thank you thank them for their
support um
and that ladies and gentlemen until next
week
is fat man beyond for this week i'm
kevin smith i'm mark bernard
tune in next time same that time
although it might probably be
saturday instead of sunday same fat
channel that never changes youtube but
it's also on my facebook channel as well
that's why i can't smoke weed for some
reason
youtube.com kevin smith or no that's
your line
yeah you do smilecraft.com smodcast.com
or
youtube.com kevin smith i'm sorry i
steal in everybody's lives
jeff's kiss
you